foreign
squared podcast we're talking today
about this book The persuaders by Anand
gidardas and we have a fascinating
conversation lined up here um Anand is
the best-selling author of The Winner
Takes all he's correspondent for the
times he's written for lots of different
Publications all in the area of politics
and he wrote the book
um The Winner Takes all made made a big
splash definitely look out for that and
his new book the one we'll be discussing
today is all about persuasion so let us
see whether he can persuade us all of
the topics in his book sir and welcome
to London and welcome to intelligence
Square thank you so much for for having
me so I wanted like there is it's a very
rich book it feels like a book that
you've been it's been bugging you is
that the case it feels like this is a
bit like you had to get this off your
chest a bit yeah it's a I mean it's a
book that I think grows out of a despair
that a lot of us face in this era which
is that we want things to change so many
people want things to change I can't
think of people I know who don't want
really big things that change and yet
rightfully many of us despair at whether
things can change whether whether we can
move uh frankly each other to change our
minds in order to be able to change
things and so I was filled with that
despair sending the United States
watching Rising authoritarianism the
growing culture of hate uh growing
disinformation it seemed more and more
impossible to get the kind of world that
we deserve the kind of world we want for
our kids if these Trends were to
continue and I didn't have an answer to
how we get out of it so I as a reporter
set out to look for people who maybe did
have an answer and and spent time with a
bunch of change makers organizers
activists Educators uh scientists
cognitive scientists occult D programmer
because that's where we are
unfortunately and and really try to
understand from them how do they think
about still reaching people still moving
Minds still winning people pulling
people into coalitions for for change in
a time when it feels so hard a time when
our own families are so divided our
societies are so divided lies and hate
fill the air how do you change people
change Minds in order to change things
and I came away with a lot of lessons
from them that filled me with much more
hope than I had at the beginning
full book like you do I mean it's a
difficult topic to discuss I'm really
happy you wrote the book partly because
it's a great book obviously but also
because this has been bothering me like
this it it bothers me that things are so
combative and I got this book and I was
like oh yes someone's like thought about
this systematically but just to get
started off let's talk about what
persuasion is because I think there's a
kind of interesting scale sometimes
between acceptable persuasion and it
sort of goes into manipulation down the
far end what what is persuasion from you
great question and particularly my
chapter on disinformation really deals
with this distinction between persuasion
and manipulation I actually think a lot
of the elements of the activity of
trying to persuade which is to
essentially try to change someone's mind
some of the elements between that and
manipulation are common some of the
basic activities what I came to
understand from writing about uh Cults
and uh and disinformation in particular
is that is that the distinct when
persuasion crosses over into
manipulation two things are going on one
the things being said are lies rather
than the truth they're not based in
evidence versus based in evidence that's
a simple straightforward distinction and
the second is when the persuasion is
really to the benefit of the Persuader
doing for their kind of Soul benefit
their profiting from trying to have you
change your mind for their purpose and
in fact what they're offering you is not
true what it it's not in fact for your
benefit or The Wider benefit
um so cult leaders uh demagogues others
are in many ways his masters of
persuasion that is really a manipulative
persuasion and in many ways the argument
of the book is that
a lot of the people I would say are good
actors in the world today who want more
democracy more human rights more
fact-based policy more of a response to
a planetary emergency I want more of us
to be included in having a good life
um have in some ways fallen short of the
bad guys when it comes to a willingness
and an ability to try to reach other
people and the book is an attempt to
correct that and say don't don't become
manipulators the way a lot of Bad actors
are but do become better persuaders do
try to reach people as they are with a
more astute understanding than a lot of
movements have about who people are how
they work how opinion formation happens
and how you can actually summon people
to a different set of beliefs a
different program
well let's start so you mentioned
already that the state of the world
which which we you know think about a
lot but it's particularly in this in
this area I think it's particularly a
topic of a discussion at the moment you
know as we're recording this it's just
uh yesterday I think that Elon Musk
actually took over Twitter and has made
these State you know he retweeted
something from a far-right conspiracy
theorist and immediately this place
Twitter like whatever you thought about
it you know it felt like some kind of
safe space ish for having discussion and
then suddenly
does this complete you know it feels
like it could be a complete about turn
obviously we don't know what's going to
happen next what what do you see in this
like in this moment where we're looking
at this and suddenly going well how are
we just going to remove our connection
with the world because we don't like the
way this guy does things how what what
do what do you see in this moment
I mean my previous book to this my third
book was called winners take all and it
was about you know how plutocracy works
and
Elon Musk in many ways embodies the core
element of what I wrote about winners
take all which is people who are the
problem
cosplaying as the solution to the
problem that they are
Elon Musk embodies many of the worst
problems of Twitter the kind of bigotry
the just the kind of worse angels of our
nature that come out to play on that
platform and the disinformation above
all he's a he's a peddler in all of
these things and so the idea that it's
not just the kind of fox in the hen
house situation but someone who is kind
of the stinking embodiment of everything
that is wrong with Twitter and there's
many things that are right about Twitter
none of them involving Elon Musk the
stinking embodiment of its problems
is now the policeman of Twitter the
owner of Twitter
um and it's very very dispiriting I mean
part of you know the larger issue of
these Tech Barons is
it's a very small number of Highly
limited men you know I don't think Elon
Musk is a serial killer I think he's a
limited man I think he's a small and
limited man I think a lot of these men
if you just look at them listen to them
talk these are men who I think probably
up till age 10 or 11 or 12 they were
tracking with the other boys you know
and then at some point these are men who
stop developing Beyond 10 11 or 12. I've
met these people like they're they're
not they're not murderers they're just
they're boys Frozen at 11 who now own
multi-billion dollar platforms and so
you have someone like Mark Zuckerberg
who if you just listen to him like
probably never had a like a great real
friendship in his life like probably
with starved for friends in his own life
now in charge of what friendship means
for the world or you have someone like
Elon Musk who if you just watch him
probably can't have a like a
conversation with someone that's a
meaningful exchange the way you and I
have probably enjoyed many beautiful
conversations in our lives he's now in
charge of what he calls the Town Square
of public conversation we have to stop
doing this thing where the people who
are worse at Things become in charge of
those things and that's what happens
when you when you live in a plutocratic
society and I think it's going to be a
very potentially dark time on Twitter
before it gets better if at all and it
may not
uh well it is I mean I it's it's a it's
a depressing thing to express but I
guess these are the things you have to
like you know people kind of hide from
these things because it's convenient and
we don't want to talk about it and so
maybe this is the the event that's going
to push all this further into the
spotlight but I wanted to pick up on
something about you know you have many
examples in the book of of you know
these very you know impressive and wise
people that you've spoken to are talking
about experience they've learned over
many many years but it's very striking
that they are all on the left of the
political Spectrum they're all
progressives they're all uh you know
they're people who believe in climate
change who believe in lbgt rights all
that kind of thing
but there are no examples from the right
now is that because you think that the
right of the spectrum is already good at
persuasion or is it because they don't
need to pursue what why is why is there
this split so striking I never write
about everything in any of my books I
know that these people who write you
know histories of humanity from you know
Turtles onward or whatever
um I write very bounded books about very
specific communities of people trying to
figure something out and this is a book
about uh a certain
political world a world of people who
want a certain kind of progress
struggling with a problem that they have
this is a book about a community of
people it's not about everything and
everyone it's about a very in a way
these you know a lot of the people in my
book I got to them separately but they
all kind of vaguely know each other and
have worked in intersecting ways it's a
book about a very uh Loosely knit group
of people who are you know largely uh
political progressives in the American
context who believe in racial progress
of a certain kind and in gender equality
and climate change Etc it's not about
how anyone can persuade anyone of
anything it's about a specific community
that is trying to build a society that
works for all and includes more people
and and and and and frankly defeats
fascism in America right now struggling
with some of the things
preventing them from achieving those
goals and a lot of the people who spoke
to me for the book were speaking a
little bit out of turn in the sense that
they were saying things that are hard to
say in their own spaces they were saying
things that maybe they hadn't said you
know in a short form space for fear of
being misunderstood but in a book you
can go into depth depth and your ideas
hopefully will be taken more seriously
and a lot of these these progressives
were saying you know we need to build a
progressive movement for the kind of
future we want that is more
Evangelical Small E Evangelical than
what we have right now that is more
interested in winning souls and
converting hearts and minds and less
interested in Purity and gatekeeping and
that's a hard thing to say but it was an
important thing to say and and so in
many ways this book is not an Omnibus
thing it it's a it's a loving
intervention in a specific Community by
a writer who shares the values of that
Community saying if if this is the
future we want we need to change our
ways to win it well this often said I
think you know the sort of um uh cartoon
drawing is that the writer's pragmatic
and the left is idealistic and that's
where it gets stuck because they've all
got slightly different ideals so I mean
and this is these are the things that
you dig into which I think are really
important but you use some phrases I
just wanted to sort of pick up on
because we can't you know cover
everything but there was this thing
about calling out and calling in explain
to us what that difference is and why it
matters well I think everyone listening
to this will know about calling out
because it's a culture that we have all
fallen into you know I would be curious
if anyone listening to this thinks they
have not fallen into it somehow it's in
many ways the culture of social media in
particular but obviously metastasizes
Beyond social media and it's a culture
of you know
yelling at people
uh of finding any way in which someone
has committed an infraction and and
going wild on it
um it's a culture of kind of not taking
people aside and saying hey quietly hey
you know you might want to think about
what you said in the meeting but instead
going straight to social media and
dumping on someone you like uh and
admire and work with
but feeling an obligation to dump on
them publicly at lest you be held
complicit
um I have certainly participated in call
out Culture by the way I think call our
culture is also very effective for
certain things there's elements of which
you know uh I think if you look at
um the the rising cries for racial
Justice around the world
um the old approaches of trying to work
within the system were quite ineffective
and so calling out abuses of power and
things like that very useful you know I
think a lot of women have found their
voices calling out patriarchy and sexism
in the workplace in ways their mothers
and grandmothers didn't have the tools
to do and it's been very effective so
there's a lot of power in calling out
also the problem is when our Democratic
discourse becomes dominated by trying to
kind of dunk on people instead of invite
them into a the better tomorrow that we
want and so I read about Loretta Ross
who's a veteran racial Justice
reproductive Justice gender justice
advocate in the U.S so in her 70s now
been an activist for more than 50 years
really a kind of godmother of the
movement for so many people
and has The credibility no one thinks
she's a moderate or a milk toast mushy
middle person this is a serious serious
person who has fought serious fights and
lived hard realities to to seek the
world she wants and in recent years she
got very alarmed by this call out
culture and she says you know the
antidote is call-in culture and she
defines a call-in as a call out done
with love which is to say
a colon is not not calling out it's not
keeping mum it's not ignoring the
patriarchy or the or the or the racist
thing that you saw at work it's calling
out with love it's finding ways to
invite people in to uh the world you
want now it's very important to make
distinctions there are some people who
are militantly racist and militantly
this is their ideology they they they're
making the comment at work because they
actually believe women are the second
sex like and you have to be clear who
those people are and need one strategy
for them Loretta says and then there's a
lot of other people
who simply were not socialized in gender
equality
and are a little too old to have gotten
the memo in time when they were
malleable and there's a lot of white
people who honestly never thought about
race until they were 40 years old right
and now suddenly it's everywhere and
there's trainings and there's TV shows
and they're a little bewildered right
and there's also people who want to like
burn churches because you know and and I
think in some ways Loretta calls this
threat assessment that progressives have
gotten bad at threat assessment making
the distinction between the person who
wants to burn down your church and the
person who doesn't understand what the
term white supremacy means or the person
who makes an awkward comment at work
about women versus the person who wants
women back in the 14th century both are
problems to be clear both are problems
but they're different kinds of problems
the different scales of problems and
this former group of people who are
confused but will there don't quite get
it we need them in our movements we
don't need them
driven to the other side and we don't
really want them Standing Outside in the
Rain banging on the door getting
frustrated no one's coming in and
eventually drifting away into the night
we want to pull them in we need
movements that are self-confident enough
to pull you in even if you don't know
the terms even if you don't get it even
if you say slightly awkward things
movement self-confident enough to
educate you inside in our spaces you
don't have to be perfect
on your own time to only then come in
well it's in I mean this is this leads
to what you sort of paint almost as the
central dilemma of persuasion for a lot
of these movements which is that they
have very strong beliefs they have a
very clear vision of society
but in order to bring some of those
people in they might need to not tote no
not shout the hard line at them quite so
much and the problem is that then you
know they
um they soften it a bit perhaps they
modify the language they modify what
they say and then their own side say
you're selling out you're not you know
the True Believer in the cause and so
they're you know the people you paint in
your book are constantly treading this
line between what is saying enough that
I am making my point
and what is saying so little I might as
well not be here that's a beautiful
beautiful summary of it and I think
that's that's
to me the Dilemma at the heart of this
book and so a couple things and first of
all I think that is most powerfully
captured in my reporting by
congresswoman Alexandria ocasio-cortez
who
you know to use a kind of gen Z phrase I
think her career tests whether it's
possible to be all of the things can you
be all the things can you be a movement
leader and an establishment player at
the same time can you be inside the
system and outside at the same time I
think in Prior Generations those
distinctions maybe meant more to people
I think a lot of people today want to
straddle those when she grew up
straddling worlds identities
um communities
and
this question of can you can you do both
hinges I think on something I call the
orchestra principle in the book which is
are our movements mature enough
movements for Progress mature enough
to recognize that just because you over
there play the oboe
I'm not doing something wrong by playing
the cello
I'm not insulting you
and your oboe playing by being a cellist
I'm not degrading your work I'm not
saying oboes are not important
by playing the cello it's just that I'm
a cellist
and you're an oboe player and we need
both of us and we actually need 100
other people playing 100 other
instruments
and while that may seem obvious in the
context of an orchestra I think that's
not obvious to a lot of people working
in political change right now and this
goes for all sides from the radical to
the moderate right so I will say on the
environment issue
this may be controversial or not I think
there's a place in the broad ecosystem
of fighting for a fair I think there's a
place for people who throw tomato soup
or paintings I'm not saying it's right
it's wrong but in the Eco historically
it's not true that things like that are
always bad a bad idea sometimes to make
the entire world talk about something
for 24 hours on moral outrage in fact
the outrage that habitable life might
end
that's what you got to do to make the
world talk about it fine right yeah I
think we would all say in retrospect if
someone had thrown paintings in 1850
to get the world's attention on slavery
right ending it I don't think any of us
today would say yeah but they shouldn't
have thrown soup at a painting I think
we would say do whatever you want to a
painting in 1850
if you think you're helping to you know
end slavery
um
I think we also need on the other end of
the spectrum a 78 year old grizzled
moderate like Joe Biden
who is Able by virtue being a 78 year
old white man at the helm of America to
make things seem reasonable and make
things to push
a climate Bill through
that seems like fine to people because
he's able to frame it in this very
Americana we're America there's nothing
we can't do we can we can save the
planet in a way that actually a
progressive might find it harder to do
and then we need someone like AOC
pushing broad goals not getting what she
wants but through pushing it influencing
Joe Biden by being on his climate task
force and we need activists and we need
people you know in in media writing very
objective stories and we need columnists
writing very tough critical things we
need we need each other AOC says in in
the book to me she says the the lesson
of kind of organizing or politics is we
need each other
and I think too often in these fights
there is this weird notion
that I play the oboe and so no one else
should play any other instrument and we
have to let go of this we have to
embrace the orchestra principle if we
want to get the world we seek
hands like a good idea but it also sends
like a whole load of culture change you
know this is not about we have drifted
into this habit perhaps partly because
of social media and because you know 280
characters you can it's easy to make a
short Point rather than Nuance new ones
point and maybe it's because the world
is so full of information just you know
at throwing things at us all the time
that actually all you can cope with is
one sentence because you know there's
just a deluge of everything so in
practice you know it's easy to idealize
oh well there's a perfect Society where
everyone kind of listens to each other
and you know they accept that they're
kind of on the same team in general even
if they disagree on the specifics in
order to get things done so how what do
you do to shift a culture do you have
any answers did any of them have any
answers to what can you other than
modeling perhaps a different way of
debate which may or may not get listened
to like how do you shift an entire
culture because that's kind of what
you're talking about to something
because it seems very easy to go down
the rabbit hole of the Twitter shouting
how do you come back
it's a great question I I think in a way
the the subjects that I'm writing about
the organizers activists scientists and
others I'm writing about are not trying
to
first shift the whole culture in a
direction of higher quality discourse in
order to get the world they want I think
they're trying to change how they and
their allies campaign
in the context of how people really are
instead of some idealized notion of how
people are
and so
while it would be nice to have better
discourse I think there's there are
methods that these organizers are using
that work
with a realistic understanding of people
so for example
the process of as one of my subjects
says to me the process of opinion
formation
is a I think we have a kind of
Enlightenment derived idea that it's a
process of reasoning I mean in many ways
you know I studied moral and political
philosophy including here in Britain and
there's such an assumption that the way
people come to their views is like you
know Factory workers are coming home and
like reading cont at the kitchen table
and then deciding where they stand on
suela braverman's new immigration policy
well
although there's a lot of philosophy
written about that kind of notion of
people as reasoning beings I think a lot
of political opinion formation is
primarily an emotional process
and what that means is it doesn't mean
that people are stupid or unreasoning it
just means that
the way of Britain might come to
a position on immigration might not be
studying the numbers of Asylum Seekers
coming over the southern border or not
or might might not be
um a a kind of
um even deep discussion with friends
about the merits and demerits of a
particular policy
I think you know whether you feel kind
of afraid
in a moment whether social change feels
overwhelming to you or not whether you
live in a town where there feels like
there's enough for everybody or a town
that feels like there's not enough for
everybody whether you live in a place
like London where you're so used to
people who don't look like you or sound
like you and you know it's fine it's
great it's fun food's better or whether
you live in a small town where you
experience that as destabilizing those
are very visceral emotional things
they're not
you know brain things uh or that part of
the brain at least
and I think basically the far right and
the demagogues and the extremists they
get what I just said they completely
understand what I just said and they
engage in opinion formation from that
understanding that it's an emotional
process
and I think broadly speaking the
political left but I would say broadly
the pro-democracy side around the world
these days
is clinging to this kind of fantasy that
humans are these reasoning beings who
are sitting around the kitchen table
studying charts and graphs to form their
opinion and therefore they speak in this
language of 1.5 degrees Celsius like
I understand scientists need to talk
about 1.5 Celsius why do you and I know
the number 1.5 Celsius that's not
how anyone thinks that's not how any
regular person thinks right like it's an
embarrassment that that is the message
of any kind of climate movement like the
way people think is are your kids gonna
have a good life
that's what moves people right are you
going to be able to breathe
right are are you are you going to
constantly be moving houses in the
future because there's a fire
engulfing each home you live in as is
already the case for many people in
California
right those are the kinds of things that
move people and the political left often
just speaks to people in this language
of kind of Brainiac language assuming
there are these kind of platonic
creatures who are studying the issues
and so in some ways this book is saying
I don't think we need everybody to have
a kind or gentler discourse I think we
need campaigners for a better world to
more realistically understand who people
are and meet them in that language speak
to them in that language and and above
all understand the emotional terrain on
which politics rests one of the things
that makes me most scared is the idea
that the worst most narrow hateful
deceptive actors on the world stage
understand human psychology better
than people who want to build a better
Society for all and that feels
unsustainable and it feels like it needs
to change
because I there's such a desire
disaster is an academic scientist this
is such a desire to use the science
everyone wants to say that the science
is behind them so there's this like
people want to think so logical but they
don't and it's not a new idea you know I
think Aristotle had a Logos Pathos and
Ethos right you know these three pillars
and one of them is logic and one of them
is emotion and one of them is do you
trust the person you're talking you know
this is not new and yet somehow some
number of thousand years later we still
haven't worked out I literally write
about those three words from Aristotle
in my chapter on Bernie Sanders you know
who built one of the most successful
mass movements in the American history
and you know around the world in recent
years
and Bernie is so committed to a kind of
logos only
and it's a deep moral commitment he
really at some level
thinks the other things are
wrong or kind of lower order appeals and
I spoke to a lot of people who worked
for him and worked around him who
basically were saying no a movement for
progress of the kind Bernie tried to
lead needs to be firing on all three of
those cylinders so that's a that from
Aristotle as always is a great way to
understand the problem actually so you
go I mean so as you go through the book
you kind of explore different facets of
of what aspects of how people are
persuading uh work and don't work and
one of the ones that you come to at the
end and I just I love the quote I I
think it came from somewhere else but um
is somebody says that uh you know Martin
Luther King didn't come didn't
wasn't remembered for that speech
because he said I have a complaint
you know that he was painting hopes he
was painting hopes of a better future
not saying this is the problem but you
set that out that the framing even just
the framing of the argument as being
almost the thing that gets missed
because everyone's so busy trying to
launch into the details that they forget
to step back and say what's the first
thing people hear and how do you see you
know do you see more good examples as
time goes on or is it just are we all
just is this the bottom and it needs to
turn well I think that you know that
observation came from one of the
subjects of the book anat Shankar Osorio
who's one of the leading Consultants on
political messages and how those of us
who want to make change want a better
world how we communicate our ideals and
the funny Paradox she's talking about
there is that if you if you want change
you kind of have two motivations I mean
you there's clearly something about now
that you don't like
there's a sense that there's a problem
there's a crisis there's something
distasteful to you about the way things
are but there's also presumably embedded
in the idea of change of the kind of
Delta of change there's presumably some
other state
that you prefer
what Martin Luther King did in that
incredible speech and so many of his
speeches was say both things right but
what did he Center in that moment I have
a dream that someday my four little
children will live in a country where
they'll be judged by the color of theirs
not by the color of the skin but by the
content of their character so he starts
that riff with what the world looks like
if and when he wins
and then he's not shy as we all know of
naming the obstructions presently
to that world
what too many of us who I think
want the kind of world he fought for
um even today well too many of us I
think do wrong is to start
with the problem
start with the crisis and often the
crisis is such a deep rabbit hole
that we actually don't get out of that
rhetorical phase right so if you think
about climate in particular there's it's
it has the aura it has such a dour Aura
to it and look
rightly so in the sense that we're
talking not about an issue we're talking
about the issue that
this may be the kind of end of the line
for us as a species that's obviously
dour
um on the other hand
we are trying to invite people we have
to invite people into a vision where
we're going to eat differently all of us
we're going to move around differently
we're going to do different kinds of
jobs than many of us do now we're going
our homes are going to look different
what we do for fun is going to be
different now
that's a lot of people to move
psychologically
physically
financially it's a lot of motion
and if we are just saying it's a problem
it's a problem it's a threat 1.5 so
dangerous wildfires this that dirty
water all of it true
people are gonna people clam up people
feel afraid right I mean they may agree
that these things are problems but you
haven't loosened them up at all you
haven't
invited them into something you've
raised a lot of the kind of reptile
brain defenses
and instead what does it look like and
I've talked to people for the book and
outside of it about this on climate this
fascinating thinking happening in the
sunrise moving and elsewhere what does
it look like what what would it have
looked like for the climate movement to
go down a different Road where this was
purely a hopeful beautiful invitation
this was an invitation for us to finally
live right finally live right with each
other finally live right with the planet
be healthier than we've ever been have a
happier relationship to Nature have a
happier relationship to our own
biochemistry there's no reason
there's no logical reason why it
couldn't have gone down that road or why
I can't go down that road now Bill Bill
McKibben great writer on climate had
this piece recently how come we never
tell people about the blimps
in a in a future where we fight climate
change there's going to be blimps again
blimps are going to be important for
cargo transport and other forms of
blimps are fun blimps are exciting
people like blimps we never talk about
the blimps instead we tell everyone they
can't eat steak anymore they can't eat
hamburgers but this is interesting isn't
it because I think I mean I could talk
about this for ages as a someone who
works in in that world but the
interesting thing I think is that the
problem that that climates us too uh
primarily one is that um
urgency if you're painting a view of a
nice world there's no reason to go there
today we could go there tomorrow or
maybe the week after that and and so I
think the urgency is interesting but
also there's a scalability and one of
the things that you do talk about in the
book is there's a lot of individual
conversations there you know especially
when you're talking about the cult
um deprogramming you know it's about
going around it's about someone's
specific view because you can't say one
thing that works for everyone you have
to and so it's not a scalable process so
how do you how do we deal with
persuading on these big societal things
when we need urgency and we need to
scale it how do we do this on a big
scale yeah I I don't think
hat painting a beautiful tomorrow as an
option grossorio calls it I don't think
that's inconsistent with a second or a
third or a fourth sentence in the riff
that is about the speed and is about the
you know
um but I long to be invited into a
project I mean you think about the
second world war and the horrors people
live through in this city and in so many
places
and you read histories of that time and
so many people's subjective experience
of it was that they had been invited
into
a life-giving thrilling project to
defend democracy against tyranny and
hatred and so people whose experience
was not having bread or having their
homes done in
in their Memoirs and in in their
experiences also remembered as a time
when they were part of something that
was good and Noble now you think about
the fight for climate do have we
succeeded at all in making people feel
any of those kinds of positive things
you think about inflation right we have
inflation right now because Vladimir
Putin did a terrible thing in Ukraine
and fortunately we live in a time in
which the world stands up for the
sovereignty of countries unlike most of
human history and so yes things are more
expensive right now and it's kind of
hard but it's for something
has any leader
galvanized us to say yeah I'm gonna try
to fight prices but also
we've dealt with hard things before
your grandparents dealt with high prices
when they dealt with you know Nazis on
the March and now we have tyrants on the
March again and just like your
grandparents buckle down lived through
it they got some help from the
government but they also just pulled
together and did what they could and
helped each other we're gonna have to do
that again that's what I would tell
people right I don't feel any world
leader is actually communicating to
people in a way that's not just like I'm
sorry the prices are high like summon us
into something people are ready to be
led right people are ready to be called
into something people are willing to
sacrifice people like to be part of
things but you have to do that work of
inviting them in and not just lecturing
people that things are dangerous things
are bad things are things are in crisis
you have to pull people into something
that they want to be part of that is as
the writer Tony Kate Bambara says the
the job of the artist is to make the
revolution irresistible you have to make
your movement not just right not just
fact-based but irresistible
um so it's very noticeable that there
are a lot of women in this book like
almost all the examples you pick on as
good persuaders glad you noticed all
women uh why
um first of all I think I was looking
for
the best people working in these fields
at political persuasion
and I think
a lot of the best people in these fields
happen to be women
um you know these are not it's not a
random assortment of people Linda
sarsour led the what co-led the largest
single day protest in American history
Alicia Garza you know co-launched the
black lives matter
um hashtag you know associated with
building that movement and help lead
that movement
um Loretta Ross you know perhaps the
most important person in the
reproductive Justice movement in America
and not shankarasario Premier messaging
consultant uh among progressives in
America
um you know AOC the most significant new
member of Congress in the history of the
United States so these are field leaders
I don't think though it's a coincidence
that so many of them are women uh many
of them women of color because I think
what they
are doing is very much their particular
approach to persuasion which combines
a certain intransigence about the world
you want
and yet
a flexibility about how you get there
about how you reach people to get there
I think in many ways as AOC actually
explained it to me very eloquently
maybe an approach particular to women
and women of color whereas and this is
you know where I was talking to AOC
about her versus Bernie Sanders right
these are people who have very aligned
political views they agree on almost
everything but he's of you know very old
white man and she's a very young woman
of color
and she said something to me about you
know I just don't have the space I'm not
granted the space by the society
to stand in front of the mountain of the
establishment and kind of yell
establishment bad media corrupt
I won't talk to the media it doesn't it
if I was a 30 year old woman of color I
did that I would still be a waitress in
you know in Manhattan
um she said
if you're someone like me you can
deplore those systems you can deplore
these structures you can deploy The
Establishment and you need to find
Pockets you can exploit was I think her
phrase you need to find cracks to get in
and so I think a lot of these women of
color in many ways by virtue of being
women of color had to both accept the
formidable
challenges the mountains in front of
them and they're by virtue of being who
they are under no Illusions about the
scale of what they face but also by
virtue of being women of color who don't
take it for granted that these systems
are going to be made
accessible to them have found a kind of
insurgent way of going about it and so
these are people who in many ways turn
the reigning theories of persuasion that
I think Prevail on a lot of the
political left in the United States and
Elsewhere on its head a lot of the
normative thing is I was having this
conversation with um with Ed miliband
yesterday here about it's kind of
persuasion by dilution right you think
about Tony Blair blairism clintonism
um persuasion by dilution I'm going to
take a noble ideal I'm going to add a
lot of water to it dilute it make it
thin gruel make it Market friendly make
you know and then I'm going to sell it
to people and what often happens is
the people who didn't like you before
still don't like you that much and the
your your base is now demoralized what a
lot of these women of color in
particular are advocating is a opposite
approach well you actually stand boldly
and bravely for ambitious things you
don't change your goals but you find
ways to communicate more effectively to
a much wider range of people than maybe
your own allies have been good at
um and so I'm no one has asked me that
yet on the book tour but it's a it's a
it was a a pointed thing about the book
and yet something I didn't make is
explicit except for who I chose and and
uh it's it's significant you're right
well it leads on to another point that
you know one of the things you say
towards the end of the book is is that
we sort of assume that you know whatever
pick your percentages but you know
there's 20 on one side of an argument
who are absolutely hardlined that's what
they believe end off there's 20 on the
other side exactly the thing same thing
opposite way around and there's this
kind of assumption that people in the
middle are sort of you know it's like a
it's like a bell curve they're sort of
there's somewhere in there they could be
they sit on a line but actually you you
know the things you're writing about
towards the end suggest that perhaps
that's not true and that seems to be
very important because that's the whole
point of consensus is that it assumes
that there's some you know we're just
going to put a circle around some group
of people and the bigger the circle is
the more it will include but you say
that's not true yeah and and here are
the parallel here to some other worlds
is interesting my mother-in-law
um Deepa Narayan is a social scientist
who wrote a series of books called
voices of the poor and her big finding
of it to summarize it was that poverty
is a situation not an identity and the
way a lot of us traditionally thought
about talked about poverty was like poor
people right an identity it's a
situation people fall in and out of it
if you go to any Village you know you
come back five years later the people
who were Rich were not poor and people
you know it's a flux uh I think we're
now talking about the homelessness in
that situation we call people
experiencing being on house or right
because it's a situation not an identity
in many ways being a moderate of what we
call moderate
is a situation not an identity and once
again we've we've miscast it
misunderstood it as an identity so when
you think about being a moderate or a
undecided voter or a swing voter when
you think about it as an identity you do
the same thing you do with unhoused
people and poor people which is you
think it's just a full it's a life it's
a it's a kind of type
and so then what you think is those
people exist in the center of that bell
curve they they live in the middle what
they want
is therefore the kind of mean between
two poles they want the average
um
and so if
the Tories are for cutting taxes and
labor is for raising them to pay for
services
you kind of Imagine like moderates want
you know neither increases nor decreases
they just want things kept as they are
well this turns out to be empirically
false a better way to understand
moderates is actually the same way we
should actually properly understand
unhoused people and and people
experiencing poverty which is that they
are in a
temporary potentially temporary state of
not feeling an allegiance to either of
the political polls
either of the N points of the spectrum
they may spend their whole life in that
torn position often they don't spend
their whole life in that torn position
often someone comes along an idea comes
along a crisis comes along and toggles
them into one or another world view
of these persuadable voters are
basically as a notion grossorio says in
the book capable of believing very
Progressive frames for looking at the
world and capable of believing very
conservative ones so think about
immigration the Border I've been
thinking about this country's grappling
with this Asylum question in recent days
I think we know a lot of people who
would just be militantly against any new
person coming to Britain we know we know
those people they exist I think we know
other people who would say come on in
we're the world is better the more the
merrier right
those are probably two kind of
minorities in the end
now are the people in the middle people
who just want like a little bit of
immigration I would submit according to
analysis of of the persuaders book that
the people in that quote unquote middle
are people who if you say to them
we are stronger when we draw on
the amazing hearts and minds of people
around the world might say yeah that
sounds right
and who if you say to them if we don't
have a secure border we have no country
to paraphrase Donald Trump might say
yeah that sounds right
sorio calls them the good point people
right whatever you say to them and and
this I I really want to this this is not
saying they're stupid or dumb what they
what they they're actually open-minded
in the sense that they don't have what
you and I probably have in this
conversation because this is our work
they don't have a fully formed worldview
right I imagine most of the things you
say on the areas you work in are backed
by thousands of books you have read and
podcasts you've listened to and right
that that's that's what you do that's
what I do well most people are not like
that thankfully otherwise it'd probably
be a kind of dull world like most people
are busy and working two or three jobs
and dealing with their kids who are
screaming and you know grabbing on their
legs and
an immigration
position is something that has not
attracted more than an hour of their
attention in the course of the last year
and so then the purpose of politics is
not
to try to stake out the most median
position you can
to wow them or attract them if this
analysis is correct the thing to do is
to suggest that your immigration
position the one you want to persuade
them of is more normal
is what people think around them is what
people do right because they are capable
of believing
that a strong border is how you have a
country and they are capable of
believing that we are stronger as a
country when all kinds of people can
live among us and so what you need to do
is have every aunt and uncle and
co-worker people they trust because they
don't trust the prime minister or the
home minister or maybe even the BBC a
big established trusted authorities are
not as trusted as they used to be but
they trust their their people
and you need those people shouting from
the rooftops about
the view of immigration you want to be
normative and often that will toggle
people in and I so I think that notion
with that myth of the moderate is
foundational to the analysis of the
persuaders we need to abandon this idea
of the middle and think about how do we
encircle people uh with messages about
the kind of world we want it's a lot
more in a way like fashion than it is uh
like you know kind of filling out an
essay on a test people the kind of pants
people decide to wear are very much
based on their perception of what other
pants other people are wearing and I
think it would serve many of us well to
realize political opinions are a lot
more like that than we may care to
realize well that is a great place to
finish so uh thank you very much it's
been a pleasure to talk to you the book
is called the persuaders winning hearts
and Minds in a divided age and I really
do I I think this should be read very
widely because I think there's a lot of
challenging ideas in there but also
there's reassurance and some Optimum for
the future which is something we all
need a bit of at the moment and so you
can buy a copy of the book from the
books tab on the right hand side of your
screen as you're watching this or from
your local Bookshop I'm Helen chersky
and you've been watching or listening to
Intelligence Squared